36 años de la mayor catástrofe nuclear
de la historia el 26 de abril de 1986 se
produjo la explosión del reactor número
4 de la planta nuclear de chernobyl en
ucrania el lugar más radiactivo del
mundo volvió a entrar en tensión el 24
de febrero cuando cayó en manos rusas
miles de tanques y soldados del kremlin
se adentraron a la zona de exclusión de
chernóbil y retuvieron hasta finales de
marzo a los trabajadores de la planta
recoletos station the place where the
station
sus tanques estaban muy cerca de la
estación sus aviones estaban por encima
de la estación y todas las armas era muy
peligroso actuar así y por eso entiendo
que pueden usar cualquier tipo de arma y
pueden hacer cualquier cosa horrible dot
de que news and off
antes sé que en the end of things hace
tres décadas una nube de lluvia
radiactiva cubrió el cielo en un radio
de miles de kilómetros cuyas secuelas
siguen visibles hoy en día la toma
temporal de chernóbil por las tropas
rusas elevó los niveles de radiación
según la organización internacional de
energía atómica ahora durante la
conmemoración del 36 aniversario la oea
visitó el lugar y señaló que si bien el
escenario es otro el nivel de
radioactividad es anormal y otro
desastre como el de 1986 por supuesto
que no porque era una situación
completamente diferente en aquella
ocasión se produjo una explosión había
un reactor en funcionamiento la
situación era completamente diferente en
este caso lo que teníamos era una
situación de seguridad nuclear que no
era normal que podría haber evolucionado
luego del accidente de 1986 al menos 31
personas murieron directamente hubo
centenares de heridos y más de 4 mil
decesos a largo plazo la guerra en
ucrania que ya supera los 2 meses volvió
a desatar los peores temores de un nuevo
desastre nuclear